- All right, let's wrap this hour up
with an awesome story of
discovery I found online.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
10-year-old Molly is
obsessed with fossils.
For years, she has scoured the
water's edge in her hometown,
looking for relics of centuries long past.
And on Christmas morning,
Christmas morning, this is crazy.
She made a once in a lifetime find:
the tooth of a giant shark
that roamed the sea 15 million years ago.
What?
It's estimated, the
trans-oceanic super predator
would've been about the
size of a Greyhound bus,
um-hmm,
and now one of its chompers
is sitting in Molly's home.
What a life!
We have her on the line right now
along with her daddy, Bruce.
What's up y'all?
(audience cheers)
- Hey (indistinct)!
- Molly, you're my hero!
This is the coolest thing ever.
I was obsessed with
megalodons and all of that
when I was a kid.
So, congrats on this big find.
What did you think when you discovered it?
- On Christmas morning, my
dad took me and my sister
out shark's tooth hunting;
after we got our waders for Christmas.
And on Christmas morning we
were in about knee deep water
and I looked over and I saw
this gigantic megalodon tooth.
And I reached in, I grabbed
it and I was so excited.
- Yes, so this tooth is-
(Kelly gasps loudly)
(audience claps)
Is a megalodon tooth.
A 5-inch tooth-
- [Kelly] That is crazy.
- And what's cool about this
is she's the first human
to ever hold this tooth.
This is just one of many
in her 400 tooth and fossil
collection that she has.
- Oh, Molly, you are officially my hero!
(audience cheers)
This is so cool.
So Bruce, y'all actually
had a local museum
actually help confirm that it was
a prehistoric shark tooth, right?
- Yeah, so we know the
curator of paleontology
at the Calvert Marine Museum,
and we've been to visit them several times
to confirm all their finds that we have.
We actually have a couple
here for you today.
We have a crocodile teeth here
and-
- Whoa!
- Molly's gonna hold this up for you guys.
And then we also have
a large whale vertebrae
that we found as well.
It's actually almost as big as
Molly's head, if not bigger.
So we've showed that to 'em as well.
But we took the shark's tooth in there
for them to take a look at
and they confirmed this megalodon
and they're blown away how big it is.
- It is so cool.
I'm just so excited for you, Molly.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know if it goes
up from here, though.
That's the most amazing find ever.
Like keep looking, but I mean
I think you hit the
jackpot right off the bat.
Thank you so much Molly and Bruce!
I'm liking your face right now-
(audience claps)
And that's not all, y'all.
Are season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show",
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
(Bruce chuckles)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- Thank you guys so much.
And thank you to all our
guests this hour, Jay Leno,
Melvin Brown, Dr. Hannah
(indistinct), Dr. Peter Grossman,
Karen, Alyssa and Amy,
y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.